[Musik]
freitagabend in berlin
fußball und feier laune
hallo sie bitte hier
der kantor an vom ordnungsamt nimmt die
personalien auf während kollegin
schomburg sich auf die suche nach der
gästeliste macht bayern gegen barcelona
in der champions league
doch schon vor den apfel droht ihr den
gästen das aus die reaktionen
entsprechend die situation
unübersichtlich abstand fehlanzeige und
die gästeliste ziemlich unvollständig
obwohl sie offen herumliegt hat sie
manche einer glatt übersehen
für diese gästeliste ausgefüllt
das hätte einen stutzig machen müssen
hat sich also würdest du diesen so eine
liste eintragen mit richtigem namen eine
späte einsicht doch an diesem abend
nicht weit verbreitet
nicht unbedingt
warum nicht
für die listen ist der betreiber
verantwortlich
ihm droht jetzt ein bußgeld nach zwei
stunden wird die personalien aller gäste
aufgenommen die den abstand nicht
eingehalten haben auch sie werden zur
kasse gebeten
im nächsten laden ein ähnliches bild
auch hier sind die gästelisten das
problem was das angeht muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen war ein katastrophaler
zustand es waren tatsächlich nur namen
und telefonnummern ist existierte keine
keine uhrzeit keine ankunft oder oder
gehzeit sozusagen
ich bin noch persönlicher man das die
sporadisch geführt wurde
wir haben also teilweise personen
festgestellt draußen als auch drinnen
die in dieser liste gar nicht wieder
aufgetaucht sind ein häufiges phänomen
hier wurde das zum verhängnis ein
brauhaus in berlin neukölln mitte juli
hat ein infizierter hier 22 menschen
angesteckt über 40 gäste ließen sich
aber trotz liste zunächst nicht
ausfindig machen
also es gab entweder falsche
telefonnummern falsche e mail adressen
oder gar kein e mail adressen oder gar
keine telefonnummern oder nur vornamen
und mit denen daten kann man natürlich
keine leute wieder finden
das jetzt drohende bußgeld könnte den
betreiber die existenz kosten weil seine
gäste falsche angaben gemacht hatten
fair findet er das nicht uns wurde vom
ordnungsamt mitgeteilt dass die
verantwortung dass die leute sich
eintragen
bei uns liegt aber dass wir eben keine
ausweiskontrolle vornehmen dürfen
und da wir keine ausweiskontrolle
vornehmen dürfen können wir nicht
sicherstellen dass die daten korrekt
sind mit den korrekten daten musste man
dann hier irgendwie umgehen
gesundheitsamt berlin neukölln an der
kontakt verfolgung arbeiten sie quasi im
akkord
das braucht es neulich ist nur ein fall
bei dem sich infektionsketten nicht
gänzlich nachvollziehen lassen
wir haben nicht 100% alle gefunden und
dass es eben für uns als gesundheitsamt
das problem wenn die menschen nicht an
ihrer eigenverantwortung auch mitwirken
diese listen zu führen
es ist kein spaß und es bringt auch
nichts donald trump oder micky maus
einzutragen damit können wir als
gesundheitsamt nicht arbeiten
logischerweise
ähnlich schwierig aber zur kontakt
verfolgung neben den listen elementar
die korona bahn app monate lang
entwickelt und dann von der
bundesregierung als coup gefeiert
ein wichtiges weiteres werkzeug bei der
eindämmung der pandemie denn meilenstein
in der korona bekämpfung das ist ein
kleiner schritt für jeden von uns aber
ein großer schritt für die pandemie
bekämpfung doch die bilanz ist gelinde
gesagt ziemlich klein
seit einführung der app mit juni gab es
38 1306 neuinfektionen in deutschland
mit saas koch 2 die müssten das positive
testergebnis selbst in der korona bahn
app eingeben
doch nur rund vier prozent haben das
tatsächlich getan
das ergeben berechnungen von statistik
experten
wir fragen den sprecher der
bundesregierung ob 4 prozent als
bisherige bilanz zufriedenstellend sind
das ist das prinzip hoffnung nachdem man
dann geht das die leute ihre ergebnisse
da wirklich auch ein geben es ist das
prinzip freiwilligkeit
es ist das prinzip freiwilligkeit das
von vornherein bei dieser app geherrscht
hat und das glaube ich auch ganz wichtig
ist um vertrauen in dieser app zu
generieren
doch mit dem vertrauen ist das so eine
sache
zunächst gab es zahlreiche technische
pannen nach neuesten erkenntnissen
funktioniert die app zum beispiel in bus
und bahn nicht zuverlässig zu viel
metall also ich hab die erfahrungen
mitbekommen dass es einfach nicht
funktioniert richtig deswegen habe ich
auch nicht installiert das bringt doch
nicht sehr viel schwitzen denn sketche
dass da irgendwie überwacht gilt wohl
ist und wohl wahr
zurück zum berliner ordnungsamt und der
gästeliste kontrolle
auch hier hat man keine angst vor
überwachung denn schließlich wird die
listen nicht nur zur corona kontakt
sondern auch zur verbrecher verfolgung
genutzt die listen sind da und die
ketten nachzuvollziehen
und wenn sie jetzt dazu
benutzt werden nochmal weiter benutzt
werden um noch mal andere sachen
nachzuvollziehen ist das irgendwie schon
ich glaube so eine befürchtung ist
völlig unbegründet
polizisten haben die möglichkeit die
notwendigkeit daten zu nutzen wenn es um
strafprozessuale ermittlungen geht man
kann darauf zugreifen
es gibt keine ausnahme was die
journalisten angeht
für die liberale opposition ein
vertrauensmissbrauch mit folgen
ich bin der meinung dass die listen so
wie sie derzeit benutzt werden nicht
rechtmäßig genutzt werden durch die
polizei es ist ja so dass teilweise ohne
richterlichen beschluss diese listen für
polizeiliche arbeit abgefragt werden die
menschen werden jetzt war sie dazu fast
genötigt in der art nothilfe um ihre
bürgerrechte zu waren dort falsche
angaben zu machen es ist ja auch schon
geschehen
das berliner ordnungsamt hat in dieser
nacht in keiner war auch nur eine
ordentlich geführte gästeliste gefunden
bei der kontakt verfolgung mit listen
und corona app sind die behörden vom
vertrauen der menschen abhängig
doch der beweis ob die politik auch
vertrauenswürdig damit umgeht
der steht noch aus
[Musik]